[Music]
get it get it get it walk it
Netflix's Fab Five are back making over
looks and lives the fact that season one
people loved it so much that they
enjoyed the show and now we're getting
to do it again and have more people see
it it's let fans Chrissy Teigen and
Meghan Trainor are addicted and only et
was on set as the guys shot a music
video for the show's theme songs with
singer Betty Boop that you'll be held by
five men at one time this mentoring
there was just we did a trust fall it
was crazy
June is national pride month and on
season two the queer eye guys mix it up
we now have women that we're making over
we also are helping people in the trans
community we're very excited about it
yeah and I think it just gives us a
chance to go a little bit deeper now
that you've gotten the chance to know
the five of us the stories just give it
a little bit more peeks into our lives
as well so excited to just show you a
little bit more of ourselves with
everyone thanks your hair sure the show
changed you guys god I think to me the
show has made me a lot more open and I
hope that's what it's doing for
everybody a lot of straight men stopped
me on the street and lift me please stop
lifting me but the nice thing about it
is that they tell me the reason why
they're so excited is because we do
truly change their life
[Music]
[Applause]